the movie begins in 1958 in a FIFA World
Cup game between Brazil and the USSR the
stadium is filled with a huge crowd of
Spectators ready to watch the
much-awaited game at the same time the
commentary talks negatively about the
Brazilian football team the scene shifts
to a locker room where a 17 year old
young Pele sits nervously waiting for
the game to begin he is the youngest
player to ever play in the World Cup
following this the movie Cuts back to
eight years ago in a local neighborhood
of Brazil several children are seen
playing football and one of them is a
nine-year-old Deco who will go on to
become Pele he polishes shoes to make
some money hoping he can afford a good
pair of boots one day dico and his
mischievous group of friends are always
desperate to play football however due
to their poor living conditions they
cannot even afford a ball to play with
thus the boys often steal neighborhood
socks and mold them into the shape of a
ball to kick it around they play the
handmade football together and toss it
around roof to roof without letting it
touch the ground one day Nico is scolded
by his mom for for returning home dirty
he is the eldest of three children his
father joao Ramos played professional
football himself but his career never
brought him much in the way of money the
next scene cuts to a local pub where
dico's father and other men are gathered
around to listen to a football
commentary of the 1950 World Cup match
between Brazil and Uruguay everyone is
wishing Brazil to win the game as they
silently listen to the commentary
meanwhile diko and his friends peer
through the broken roof of the pub they
are also eager to know the result of the
ongoing final match unfortunately Brazil
loses the game dico's father bursts into
tears after learning the final result
dico watches this from above and he too
begins to cry after Brazil's devastating
loss in the 1950 final Deco makes the
bold and unlikely promise to his father
that someday he will go on to win a
World Cup for Brazil the following day
dico joins his mother to work they are
set to clean the house of a wealthy
Factory owner there his mother explains
that his father struggled to earn a
living as a football player after a leg
injury and that's the reason that she
doesn't want dico to play football as
his mother steps out of the room a group
of rich kids including the house owner's
son Jose arrives and starts talking
about different football players dico
overhears the boys discussing the local
Youth Tournament he also learns that a
famous professional Scout will be
attending the tournament intrigued he
interrupts the boys by saying the name
of a famous football player ballet but
mispronounces it as Pele the rich kids
make fun of him nicknaming him Pele a
name Deco initially loathes soon after
his mother arrives at the scene and
makes him apologize to Jose although he
is not at fault before leaving Deco
grabs a piece of newspaper mentioning
the local tournament later he informs
about the tournament to his friends and
convinces them to participate wasting no
time Deco and the boys approached the
organizers and enlist themselves in it
although the boys are poor and do not
even have shoes to play in the
tournament they have amazing football
skills they leave almost all the teams
behind and make it to the final only to
realize that they will have to face
Jose's team in the last match Jose mocks
dico and his friend calling them the
shoeless team as they do not have any
shoes to wear I guess no one ever said
athletes were clever the insults deeply
affect Deco and his team oh that's weird
so they decide to get the shoes however
they have no money suddenly one of them
comes up with a plan to steal stacks of
peanuts from nearby vendors and sell
them to get secondhand shoes the boys
immediately agree and proceed with their
plan during the act the vendors noticed
Deco and his friends stealing their
peanut sacks and thus a Chase ensues
thankfully the boys managed to outsmart
them and reach the market while selling
the peanuts Jose and his group
approached dico and start making fun of
his team once again this time however
Deco has had it so he punches Jose in
Anger one thing leads to another and the
two sets of groups get into a massive
brawl later at home dico's mother is
worried to see her son all bruised up
she asks him what happened and dico
simply lies that it was his teacher who
did the beating uh-oh this infuriates
his mother so she promises to talk to
the teacher the next day however dico's
father interrupts and says that he will
be deal with the teacher and insists
that she focus on her work the next day
he takes dico to work on the way he
reveals that he knows about the fight
and the tournament but instead of
getting angry dico's father suggests he
put aside his feelings and focus on his
skills to win the final game he advises
his young wannabe football player's son
that if he wants to play professionally
he can't be ashamed of who he is knowing
his father is by his side dico becomes
happy and determined to play his best in
the tournament the big day finally
arrives and everybody is cheering up for
Jose and his team of Rich boys once
again the Arrogant boy makes fun of dico
and continues calling him Pele meanwhile
dico and his team finally wear the
secondhand shoes they bought by selling
the stolen peanuts however the boots are
too big for the young boys once the
match starts dico and his friends are
slowed by their oversized boots Jose's
team takes this as an opportunity so
they score goal upon goal making the
score 6-nothing the most goals scored in
one game in the history of all soccer as
the match progresses dico gets angry
when the opponents begin to play foul
and Jose continues to tease him but just
when he is about to attack Jose in a fit
of rage he sees his father in the
audience and recalls what he had said
the other day dico then decides to take
off the uncomfortable football boot to
ease himself and play football as they
did in the streets he takes the ball
Dodges over his opponents just dangles
their asses silly and surprises the
crowd with his amazing skills scoring
the first goal soon after this all of
his teammates begin to take off the
oversized boots and play the game their
own way dico and his team dominate the
game as they pass the ball through their
opponents thanks to dico's Showcase of
incredible skills his team almost pulls
off a dramatic comeback by the end they
managed to push the score to 6-5 they
lose the game because of time
constraints however everyone is
mesmerized by dico and his team's game
so they give a standing ovation to them
everyone begins to chant his name as
Pele soon after the tournament dico and
his friends spot the vendors from whom
they had stolen peanuts the other day
the young boys begin to run away and go
into the forests however one of his
friends trips over a branch and hurts
his leg dico helps him and takes him to
a small cave nearby suddenly it starts
to rain heavily and this triggers a
landslide above the cave that the boys
are Sheltering in Deco whom we will now
address as Pele manages to get out
however the injured friend is stuck
inside the cave which is soon
overpowered by the landslide in the next
scene the vendors arrive and dig the boy
out unfortunately he is already dead by
the time he is rescued a distressed Pele
returns home and sobbingly explains
everything to his mother he blames
himself for the death of his dear friend
for days Pele remains shot and continues
to blame himself for the tragic accident
to distract him his father takes Pele to
his workplace there he shows his son
some football tricks by playing with
some mangoes initially Pele ignores his
father for some days but later starts
joining him then practicing with the
mangoes cut to some years later Pele is
now 15 years old and continues to assist
his father in janitorial work while
practicing with mangas during break time
one day his mother other notices him
practicing with his father and finally
realizes pele's passion for football she
decides to call a professional Scout
named waldemar de Brito to watch him
play when Pele returns home he is happy
to see debrito waiting for him debrito
also a former member of the Brazilian
national football team suggests Pele
participate in the trials of the local
football team de Brito eventually
convinces pele's family to let the
budding Phenom leave home and try out
for Santos FC a professional football
club in the next scene Pele begins his
professional training with Santos FC
however it becomes difficult for him to
adapt to the European style of playing
during practice he starts out poorly and
is even scolded by his coach a couple of
times discouraged by his play Pele
decides to return home and continue
working with his father in the train
station de Brito approaches the young
boy and inquires what is the reason
behind his sudden departure Pele replies
that he thinks his way of playing is not
accepted in the club and even the coach
isn't satisfied with his performance
debrito explains that his way of playing
football is considered the Ginga style
which was famous during the era of
slavery the slaves used to practice a
self-defense art form of the same to
defend themselves from their cruel
Masters they fled to the forests and
continued practicing Jinga after slavery
was abolished the slaves found out that
their Jenga style was no more in use
therefore in order to preserve it they
used the style to play street style
football ever since then Jenga has been
in practice however Brazilians blamed
Gene Castile to be the cause of the loss
in the 1950 World Cup this is why most
coaches want to train youngsters
according to traditional and European
style football techniques debrito then
suggests Pele stay and prove to the
world his talent or return home as a
coward after he leaves Pele thinks for a
while and eventually decides to continue
training with Santos FC the next day he
starts off poorly as he is asked by the
coach to play according to the game plan
however the match doesn't work in his
team's favor so Paley is scolded by his
coach and looked down on by his
teammates suddenly the young player
recalls his father's advice and how he
practiced with mangos he also sees
debrito cheering for him so Pele decides
to play the game the way he knows soon
after Pele gets the ball and Dodges
through his opponents he then kicks the
ball acrobatically like how he used to
with the mangos in this way Pele scores
the first professional goal of his
career at the age of 15. his coach along
with the spectators are surprised to see
pele's amazing skills as the days pass
Pele continues to play with other teams
across the country and make a name for
himself despite being the youngest
player to participate in a professional
tournament surprisingly he moves up from
the youth Squad to the reserve Squad and
eventually works his way up to the
professional level team his Orthodox
Jenga style of play is of great concern
to his coach but he can't argue with
results as Pele leads the team to
several victories one day Pele decides
to give a surprise visit to his parents
and also bring along some gifts to the
family he gifts a radio to his father
and they decide to listen to the
announcement of the national squad for
the 1958 World Cup Pele doesn't believe
that he will be selected as he is too
young to play in the national team but
despite this they decide to listen to
the announcement and to their surprise
Pele gets selected in the next scene
Pele joins the national team and
everyone seems to be friendly however
the reporters there begin to question
Brazil's style of playing they even make
fun of the Genghis style calling it
outdated and boring to make matters
worse the national football coach also
confronts Pele and warns him against
playing the Genghis style of football
the following day Pele decides to play
the traditional European style of
football as suggested by his coach
however it becomes difficult for him to
adapt to this style in the process he
trips and hurts his knee that's okay
he's just diving when the doctor
examines him he points out that Pele
might be ruled out of the world cop due
to his injury later that night an upset
Pele Rings his mother to inform the
family about the recent incident and the
likeliness of him not being able to play
in the World Cup however his mother
tells him to have faith and advises him
to take care of himself the 1958 World
Cup finally begins and the Brazilian
team manages to win a couple of Starting
Games however due to the brutality of
the matches several teammates are
injured therefore the coaches left with
no choice but to ask an unfit Pele to
play the ongoing match initially scared
Pele makes a couple of excuses but the
coach forces him to play for the country
before the players head to the field the
coach once again reminds Pele to play
traditional European style football or
else soon Pele joins his teammate on the
ground and they barely make it past the
USSR to reach the semi-final with France
in the semi-final the Brazilian team is
utterly dominated and France even
manages to score a goal during the
interval Pele looks upset as he notices
the injured players in the dressing room
demotivated he asks one of them to
replace him in the second half however
the teammate refuses and reveals that he
is not in a sound mental state to play
the game additionally he tells Pele that
he is tired of playing European style
football and further suggests Pele play
the Jenga style so that he can truly
showcase his skills and hopefully win
the game bolstered by his teammate's
support Pele erupts onto the field with
his Gengar style of play he displays
remarkable speed athleticism and field
Vision to score three goals in a
semi-final 5-2 demolition of France a
few days later during a press meeting
between the two finalists teams Brazil
and Sweden the Swedish coach mocks
Brazil's Jenga style of playing and says
that they will lose the World Cup final
just as they did in 1950 frustrated
Brazil's coach storms out of the meeting
at night Pele Rings his father to inform
him about the situation but the latter
advises him to try to unite his
teammates so they can win the match the
following day during breakfast Pele
challenges his teammates to kick the
ball to the nearest Lighthouse without
dropping it thus this would need
teamwork the teammates reluctantly agree
and they start kicking the football
without touching the ground upon seeing
this the coach realizes he was wrong for
teaching the boys traditional European
formations and later confronts them He
suggests the team play the Jenga style
in the final and show the world the
Brazilian way of playing football it's
the World Cup final and the Brazilians
all around Have Eyes on their TV for the
live show of the match on the ground the
match begins and surprisingly the
Swedish team manages to score the first
goal within four minutes of the game
pelea is continuously sidelined by the
opponents as it turns out their big game
plan is to stop Pele from getting the
ball however the Brazilian team
maintains their form and soon after Pele
gets the ball and shoots an incredible
goal and then the team Nets four more to
make it a final 5-2 win over Sweden with
this Brazil wins for the first time in a
World Cup pele's teammates storm onto
the field to congratulate him and lift
him up onto their shoulders the scene
then shifts to the real moment when
Brazil won the final in 1958 pelea has
cheered by his teammates in the final
scene it is revealed that the Brazilian
president declared Pele a national
treasure in 1961 the goat of football
holds the remarkable record for most
goals scored and is also the youngest
player to score a goal in a World Cup he
is also the only player to win three
FIFA World Cups Pele passed away on
December 28 2022 10 days after the 2022
FIFA World Cup his last post was a
congratulatory message to another icon
of football Lionel Messi subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching